Be sure to subscribe to Lang Focus and
click the notification button.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the lane focus channel and my
name is Paul.
Today's topic is the French language or
as it's called in French.
French is a language that really needs
no introduction.
It's the official language of France of
course,
but it's an official language of 29
countries in total.
That includes other countries in Europe,
namely Belgium,
Switzerland,
Luxembourg,
and Monaco,
numerous countries in Africa,
Canada,
where it's spoken mainly in the province
of Quebec,
the Caribbean,
South America,
and the South Pacific.
It's estimated that French is spoken by
between 80 and 110 million native
speakers,
but that number doesn't give us a full
picture because between 140 and 180
million people speak it as a second
language.
The majority of them in Africa,
French is also an important language of
international diplomacy and used to be
the main global Lingua Franca.
French is a member of the Gallo Romance
Branch of the Romance Language family,
which descended from vulgar Latin,
just like all romance languages did.
It's also part of a smaller subset of
Gallo romance called Lung [inaudible],
a dialect continuum in northern France,
southern Belgium,
and the channel islands,
which includes Falciani,
the dialect from which standard French
derived and it's closest relatives
history in the second century bce
present de France was part of the goal
region,
which also included Belgium,
Switzerland,
northern Italy and parts of Germany and
the Netherlands.
The gold spoke Galician,
which was not a unified language,
but rather a series of Celtic languages
and dialects,
but very little is known about golish.
The Roman republic conquered Gaul in the
second and fourth centuries bce and in
order to become Roman citizens,
goals were required to adopt the Roman
way of life,
including their language,
Latin,
being able to speak Latin became a way
to gain social status,
economic opportunity and employment in
the civil service.
Over the next few centuries,
golish Latin bilingualism became more
common and eventually Latin dominated
and the golish language has disappeared.
The common people spoke vulgar,
Latin,
a vernacular form of Latin that differed
from the formal written language and
also different from place to place
throughout the Roman Empire.
And I'm feeling Deja Vu right now
because I think I talk about this in
every video about a romance language.
Beginning of the year three 75 ce,
the GERMANIC invasions began and
gradually replaced the western Roman
Empire with Germanic Kingdoms.
The fall of the empire accelerated the
divergence of vulgar Latin into distinct
romantic dialects.
The dialects of northern goal,
which would later develop into the lung,
doyle changed more than others because
of frequent contact with Germanic
languages like frankish spoken by the
elite.
The frankish elite spoke both frankish
and romantic and after a while they
spoke mainly romantic dialects,
but frankish left an important footprint
on those dialects.
French,
which developed from one of these
romantic dialect,
got approximately 550 words from
frankish or around 13% of the total
number of loan words in French,
and it's phonology was greatly
influenced as well.
This is a large part of why French
phonology is so distinct from other
romance languages.
It developed from the German ised
romantic speech of the Frankish.
He leads,
but I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let me back up for a minute.
Old French,
romantic dialects.
Gradually grew into distinct languages
and by the eighth century,
the dialects of the northwestern part of
the frankish kingdom grew into a number
of dialects that are collectively
referred to as old French,
which later began to be called the
[inaudible].
As they developed further,
there was no standard form of old
French,
but rather a dialect continuum.
One of those dialects from Sia,
well spoken in a small area around
Paris,
and it's the old French variety from
which standard French developed for
[inaudible] is a modern word.
At the time,
the dialect was actually cold.
Frost sweat that name later evolved into
Francais,
say the name of French.
Today,
the king of the upper classes spoke
frankish Latin was the language of
writing and the Coleman people who were
mostly illiterate spoke one of the
various dialects,
but over the next few centuries,
the upper classes began to speak from
[inaudible] under King Louie.
The ninth from Sudan gained new prestige
and was adopted by the upper classes in
cities around the kingdom.
The Coleman people continued to speak
local dialects and Latin continued to
serve as the language of education,
the courts and academia.
Throughout the Catholic world.
Under King Phillip,
the fourth French began to be used as
the language of official documents and
government and began to compete with
Latin as a written language.
Middle French.
During the middle French period,
the French changed dramatically,
particularly in its phonology,
but scholars tried to maintain the
language,
which means that the written French of
today often reflects the pronunciation
of French.
Before those changes took place,
old French had two cases retained from
Latin,
but those also disappeared in the middle
French and this resulted in the word
order of French being more fixed.
This was during the renaissance period
when the cultural dominance of Italy
influenced French 8,000
Italian vocabulary words entered French
800 of which are still in use today.
In the 16th century,
King Francois,
the first sign of the ordinance of
vehicle which made French the official
language of administration instead of
Latin.
The Catholic church fought hard against
this move and didn't want the holy
scriptures to be translated into common
languages,
but their efforts ultimately failed.
The printing press also helped to spread
French because more people could read
and understand it.
Then they could Latin.
So publishers printed more books in
French.
Modern French in the 17th century,
French took the place of Latin as the
Lingua Franca of Europe and the Catholic
world.
This was also the century in which
grammarians sought to standardize proper
French with the publishing French
grammars and the Academy Frost says was
founded in 1635 with the mission of
promoting proper French and preserving
that form of the language.
At that time,
only a small percentage of the people in
France actually spoken French.
Most of them spoke other along the oil.
The other regional varieties of speech.
Later in 1880 universal education would
be established and French would be made
to the soul language of education and
the only language permitted to be spoken
at school.
This measure would push standard French
to be near universally spoken throughout
the country.
In the 18th century,
French became the language of
international diplomacy,
used an international legal documents
and so on reaching a status similar to
the status of English.
Today,
French maintained the status until the
time of the first world war.
French may not currently be the most
widely spoken global Lingua Franca,
but it's still an important diplomatic
language.
It's one of the official languages of
the UN and the European Union,
international courts as well as aid
agencies and NGO's.
Why is French spoken in so many
countries around the world?
That's because in the 17th century,
France began establishing colonies all
over the globe.
After losing most of these colonies in
wars with other colonial powers,
France began a second colonial empire
establishing mainly colonies in Africa,
Southeast Asia,
and the South Pacific.
Aside from a few overseas departments
and territories of France,
these colonies no longer exist,
but French is still spoken in many of
those places.
So what is French like?
French naturally shares a lot in common
with other romance languages and
Speakers of romance languages.
We'll find it familiar and
comprehensible in many ways,
especially in its written form.
But it's phonology is quite distinct
from other romance languages and its
pronunciation is often not intuitive
based on the spelling because it's
orthography often reflect pronunciation
from an earlier time pronunciation and
orthography.
In old French,
there were diphthongs and trip thongs.
But these became simple vowels,
so today in French,
there are vowels that look like
diphthongs are trip thongs,
but represents the vowel sounds.
For example,
fruit flir.
You can see that all of these words
contain a single vowel sound,
but are spelled like diphthongs are trip
thongs.
There were also a number of nasal
vowels.
Typically when an n or an m comes after
a vowel,
it's not pronounced,
but the proceeding vowel is nasal ised.
For example,
from shrimp pumps.
Here's a phrase with several nasal
vowels.
Bovine below.
There are some exceptions.
For example,
when an adjective or noun takes a
feminine ending eat,
there's shank with a nasal vowel,
but then there's Shin with an oral vowel
and an end zone.
There are also a number of diacritics or
written accents in French.
Four of these appear on vowels.
The first is the [inaudible] Xle,
or a cute accent,
which is used on the letter e.
This represents an a sound,
for example,
Luke ethic.
Then there's the exome glove or grave
accent.
With Anu.
It's used mainly to distinguish between
otherwise,
similarly looking and sounding words.
For example,
oop,
meaning where versus Ooh meaning or with
Ie.
The grave accent indicates that the
sound is like the Ian Bet as opposed to
an e with an acute accent,
which sounds like a,
then there's the excellent dilemma.
This shows that two side by side vowel
symbols are pronounced independently.
For example,
chorus.
He don'ts,
I mean in coincidence.
Then there's the circumflex accent which
can appear on any vowel.
This indicates that the vowel was
historically followed by an s for
example.
In fact,
meaning a party.
Just to illustrate,
let's look at the Italian cognates of
this word,
Huna.
Festa.
Notice that there's an s in the Italian
word in an earlier form of French.
There was an s after the eat and before
the tea siggy or Savilla,
which indicates that the c sounds like
an s.
Please note that the [inaudible] is not
used when the consonant comes before an
I or an e because a c in that position
is always pronounced like an s.
Anyway,
there were also silent consonants in
French consonants that are written but
not pronounced.
This includes most consonants that come
at the end of a word.
For example,
shut hope vet.
There is the masculine form of an
adjective,
but in the feminine form of adjectives,
the final consonant is pronounced and in
writing and he is placed after it.
So there's fair but that,
but not all final consonants are silent.
Certain consonants are often but not
always pronounced at the end
specifically see R,F
and l,
the consonants in the word careful.
For example,
after the other positive grammar,
let's look at word order in very simple
Svo sentences.
The word order of French is basically
the same as English.
For example,
here's a sentence meaning he likes
movies.
[inaudible] word for word.
It's he likes the films,
so we have subject,
verb,
object,
but already we see that something is
different from the English sentence
because there's a definite article in
English.
The definite article would only be used
to refer to specific films,
but in French the definite article is
also used for general statements like
this.
Articles in French are somewhat complex.
We'll come back to those a little later.
The word order starts to become more
different from English when there are
object pronouns in the sentence.
So there's this sentence,
meaning I see the building,
she was worried about smoke,
but then there's jut have one meaning.
I see it word for word,
it's I it.
See,
you see that the object Pronoun comes
before the verb,
not after it.
And then there are sentences with a
direct object.
Pronouns end,
an indirect object.
Pronouns [inaudible] this means Paul
gives me money.
Paul to me,
gives some money.
Now let's change the direct object to a
Pronoun Miller done.
This means Paul gives it to me word for
word.
It's Paul.
To me it gives and if we make it
negative,
it becomes even more different from
English.
[inaudible] the [inaudible] and pop
constitute the negative.
So word for word,
it's Paul negative.
To me it give not.
There are more differences beyond these,
but that gives you a bit of an idea for
now.
Basically the word order is more similar
when there are no object pronouns.
Let's briefly look at a few other
grammatical features.
A French gender.
All nouns have either masculine or
feminine.
Gender and French.
The gender of the noun is also reflected
in articles before the nouns and
adjectives that modify it.
For example,
the word for hat shut boob is masculine
Lou Shapiro.
Blue means the blue hat,
the definite article and the adjective
are masculine.
The word for shirt shimmies is feminine.
Less should means blue means that the
blue shirt,
the definite article in the adjective or
feminine articles.
There are three types of articles in
French,
definite,
indefinite and partitive.
All three types of articles have
masculine,
feminine and plural forms and definite
and positive articles have special forms
before avowal.
What are positive of articles?
You might ask?
Well there indefinite,
but they refer to a vague unspecified
quantity often for food or abstract
qualities.
For example,
[inaudible] you get to meaning I would
like some cake.
The amount of cake is vague,
so we use the part of article.
Nouns are almost always proceeded by
articles in French unless there's a
different determiner before the now such
as a possessive pronouns like mine or a
demonstrative pronouns like that.
Negation before we saw the phrase bone
in the middle of them,
which is negative with the negation in
two parts.
No and pot,
but it's not always pot that's used.
No [inaudible] means never.
For example,
even a [inaudible] means he never works.
Yeah,
it means nothing.
For example,
an emotional yeah means she eats nothing
or she doesn't eat anything.
Best son means nobody.
Zuni Zuni Besson means I saw no one or I
didn't see anyone.
Leon and pest son can also be the
subject of the sentence best so never
knew means nobody came and the end of
CPC means nothing happened.
Verbs.
The verb system of French is fairly
complex.
If we include all of the compound
tenses,
moods and aspects,
there are 14 tenses plus the imperative
form.
Let's look at a couple of the basic
tenses.
He's fucked.
Liz shimmies.
This means he's wearing the shirt is the
present tense.
Third Person,
masculine,
singular conjugation.
But let's change this to the future
tense means this means he will wear the
shirt.
Now let's change this to the imperfect
tense buffet to mean he was wearing the
shirt.
[inaudible].
The imperfect shows that the action was
ongoing at a certain point in the past.
If you want to express that the action
was completed at a certain point in the
past,
you can use the passe composition
bicycle boozy,
either Taylor shoney's,
that means he wore the shirt.
You can see that in the past a
composite,
there is an auxiliary verb of Y,
which means to have and it's followed by
the past participle of the main verb,
Dok Day.
For some verbs in the past,
say composition,
particularly reflexive verbs and those
showing movement,
a different auxiliary verb is used to
be.
For example,
eat is salty dynamism.
This means he left the house.
You can see that the auxiliary verb is a
form of ed rather than a voir vocabulary
as a romance language,
most French vocabulary is of Latin
origin and some of the more modern
vocabulary.
Our hybrid words built from both Latin
and Greek roots.
English vocabulary has been greatly
influenced by French,
so English speakers will likely notice a
lot of French words that look like
English ones,
the way they're pronounced.
However,
it's quite different.
For example,
information,
Phil Messer,
danger g,
double dewberry license,
the salts,
and there are a significant number of
false friends between French and
English.
Words that look the same but actually
mean something else.
For example,
actually actually more active and more
doesn't mean actually it means currently
or right now assist,
assisting a sea state means to attend.
Then there's attend at dawn.
A thumper doesn't mean to attempt.
It means to wait.
There are quite a lot of false friends
like this,
so you can never assume that a French
word has the same meaning as a similar
looking English word.
Now let's look at one final sentence and
see what we find.
Here's the sentence,
meaning she went for a walk to the park
yesterday and sip on Neil back.
Yeah,
word for word.
It's she herself took for a walk to the
park yesterday.
L is the third person.
Feminine,
Singular Pronouns.
Next we have the verb phrase and this
year as a reflexive verb,
sip is the third person.
Pronouns used for reflexives.
It means herself or himself.
Next we have the third person,
singular present tense form of Ed.
This is used as the auxiliary verb for
the passe composite for reflexive verbs
come [inaudible] is the past participle
of the main verb.
This is the feminine singular form,
which takes an extra e at the end by
itself.
It's a transitive verb,
meaning to take for a walk,
but the reflexive form used here means
to go for a walk.
Here we have a preposition meaning to
the two by itself is ah,
but when used before the masculine
singular definite article,
they are replaced by bull.
For Feminine Singular,
it would be alive and for plural it
would be,
oh fuck is the noun meeting park.
So this whole phrase means to the park.
Yes is the advert meaning yesterday.
As you can see,
French is a very interesting language
for speakers of English or romance
languages.
There are probably many elements of
French that seemed familiar,
but then when you get into the details
of the language,
there might be aspects that seem complex
or challenging,
but French is a highly rewarding
language and by learning French you will
not only be able to communicate with
French speakers,
but you will also open the door to a
whole new world of culture,
literature,
cinema,
and history.
The question of the day for native
speakers of French.
In this video I focused mainly on
standard Parisian,
French,
but what regional differences are you
aware of?
Are there any differences in the French
spoken at Belgium,
Switzerland,
Quebec,
et Cetera,
and for learners of French?
What aspects of French have you found
challenging and how have you dealt with
those challenges?
Leave your answers in the comments down
below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram and be sure to subscribe
and turn on notifications if you want to
know whenever I publish a new video and
once again thank you to all of my
patrion supporters,
especially these people right here on
the screen for their monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.